moi vous raisonner comme si l'objectif
du gouvernement français comme d autres
gouvernements c'est un objectif de qui
vise à protéger la santé de la
population
moi pour en étant provocateur moi je ne
pense pas je pense que c'est un une
justice que gesticulation politico
médiatique parce que ma foi lorsque les
médias parlent de quelque chose tous les
jours si on ne fait rien au niveau
politique c'est intenable si les médias
parlent de quelque chose ou pas ça c'est
extrêmement arbitraire je veux dire
pourquoi parle-t-il des jeux des mordus
covit subitement depuis deux ans et
pourquoi ne parle-t-il pas des 800 morts
par jour de maladies cardiovasculaires
et de cancer ca faudra parler tous les
jours puisque il y en a dans les
chaumières coreldraw mobilité là c'est
pas le courtage c'est pas que c'est pas
contagieux mais ça fait 800 morts par
jour donc là là moi je n'en crois rien
une réalité très réel intérêt objectif
et on s'éloigne pas de la santé je veux
dire les populations à travers le monde
vont être de plus en plus remuante face
aux problèmes économiques et
environnementaux grandissons est pour
moi la santé est un prétexte fantastique
pour maintenir la laisse sur ces
populations donc pour réduire leur
liberté de la liberté pour moi la
gestion de l'épidémie par les tâches
c'est exactement la même chose que sa
gestion du terrorisme d accidents de la
route ou la consommation de drogue sous
prétexte de chasser le drogué le
chauffard le terroriste ou le
contaminant ou la sous-catégorie du non
vaccinés
c'est une volonté affichée de surveiller
de contrôle et donc les individus alors
là tout le monde s'aperçoit des mesures
qui sont mises en place effectivement
al'inverse de ce qui se passe lorsque la
santé et mis en balance des intérêts
avec les intérêts économiques comme on
l'a dit tout à l'heure là par contre les
textes législatifs et les moyens humains
et techniques pour les appliquer c'est
sans limite donc moi de mon point de vue
si vous pouvez encore une fois je pense
que cette épidémie mais comme encore une
fois le terrorisme comme les accidents
de la route ou code la consommation de
drogue je ne suis pas sûr que la santé
de la population sur l'objectif
réellement poursuivis à
[Musique]